on va prendre la direction de l'elysée à
présent pour faire un point justement
sur ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état dans
son discours de 19 minutes ce soir on va
retrouver nadège abderrazak devant le
palais de l'elysée
nadège bonsoir vous avez suivi
évidemment ce discours pour rt france
que faut-il en retenir précisément mais
écoutez magali emmanuel macron a
commencé son discours par de bonnes
nouvelles pour les français le passage
en zone verte de tout l'hexagone
exceptés les territoires de guyane de
mayotte avec une reprise plus forte du
travail et la réouverture des bars et
restaurants en ile-de-france est les
frontières françaises rouvre ouvre à
partir de demain les déplacements en
dehors de l'union européenne seront
possibles à partir du 1er juillet dans
les pays qui auront réussi à maîtriser
l'épidémie l école sera obligatoire pour
tous à partir du 22 juin le président de
la république a appelé à éviter au
maximum lé rassemblement qui sont de
potentiels foyers de contamination du
virus ans selon lui
il a aussi confirmé cette date du 28
juin pour le second tour des élections
municipales il ne faut pas baisser la
garde il faut continuer à vivre avec le
virus
apprendre à vivre avec le virus et
respecter les gestes barrière il a
insisté le chef de l'état sur ce point
et malgré un bilan humain qui atteint
près de 30000 morts le chef de l'état
s'est dit satisfait de ce bilan la
france n'a pas à rougir de ce bilan
puisque des dizaines de milliers
d'autres vies ont été sauvées grâce à la
politique du gouvernement à ce sujet je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous n'avons pas à rougir mes chers
compatriotes de notre bilan
des dizaines de milliers de vies ont été
sauvées par nos choix
par nos actions nous avons su doubler en
quelques jours nos capacités de
réanimation organiser des transferts de
centaines de patients entre régions et
avec les pays voisins approvisionner nos
commerces réorienter notre production
industrielle
inventer des nouvelles solidarités la
période a montré que nous avions du
ressort de la ressource que face à un
virus qui nous a frappés plus tôt et
plus fort que beaucoup d'autres nous
étions capables d'être inventif réactif
solide
emmanuel macron a aussi appelé à une
réorganisation de l'état syndicats
associations et citoyen seront
sollicités on l'écoutait suger j'en ai
la conviction profonde
l'organisation de l'état et de notre
action doit profondément changer tout ne
peut pas être décidé si souvent à paris
face à l'épidémie
les citoyens les entreprises les
syndicats les associations les
collectivités locales les agents de
l'état dans les territoires ont su faire
preuve d'ingéniosité d'efficacité de
solidarité faisons-leur davantage
confiance libérons la créativité et
l'énergie du terrain c'est pourquoi je
veux ouvrir pour notre pays une page
nouvelle donnant des libertés et des
responsabilités inédite à ceux qui
agissent au plus près de nos vies
liberté responsabilité pour nos hôpitaux
nos universités nos entrepreneurs nos
mères et beaucoup d'autres acteurs
essentiels
emmanuel macron a appelé les français à
être plus solidaires il a condamné le
racisme l'antisémitisme et toutes formes
de discrimination et dans le même temps
il a tenu à rendre hommage au policier
gendarme garant de l'ordre républicain
emmanuel macron qui devrait à nouveau
s'exprimer pour une cinquième allocution
depuis le début de la crise ce sera
courant juillet merci beaucoup nadège
pour ce point complet sur le discours d'
emmanuel macron ce soir